you might have noticed that Donald Trump
and the Republicans have sort of dialed
back their haste to repeal Obamacare the
Affordable Care Act and more importantly
Donald Trump actually said this week
that the replacement for Obamacare which
he is describing as quote something
terrific could take up to a year leaving
maybe 20 or 30 million people uninsured
in the meantime interestingly but not
surprisingly it turns out that the same
Republicans who want to repeal Obamacare
because it's so terrible actually like
what Obamacare does and don't even
realize that repealing Obamacare would
put an end to those revisions that they
like we have a morning consult poll
which shows that for example fifty three
percent of republicans most republicans
don't realize that if you repeal
obamacare you disable those insurance
subsidies as well as the medicaid
expansion which have made health care
free or cheaper for millions and
millions of people republicans and Trump
supporters right the critics of
Obamacare don't seem to know what it is
or what it does let's put up the data
from a Kaiser Family Foundation Health
tracking poll look at some of the data
here for example 83% eighty-three
percent of Trump voters like the
provision of Obamacare which allows
young adults to stay on their parent's
insurance plans until their age 26
eighty-three percent 75% of Trump voters
are in favor of eliminating
out-of-pocket costs for preventive
services something that Obamacare does
seventy-two percent of Trump voters like
the health insurance exchanges where
small businesses and people can shop for
insurance and compare prices and
benefits 71 percent of Trump voters like
the Obamacare provision which closes the
Medicare prescription drug coverage gap
that exists if you read down this long
list you will notice that the only items
that have under fifty percent support
from Trump voters are the mandate
require
sharing employers with 50 or more
employees to offer health insurance or
pay a fine and the mandate that requires
all Americans to have health insurance
or pay a fine Republicans want all the
stuff that Obamacare does but they don't
want the aspects that make it all
affordable it's hilarious that the right
criticizes the left because the left
wants quote free stuff it's actually the
right that wants the free stuff the
right wants all of the provisions of
Obamacare everything that it affords
people but they don't want the mechanism
that actually pays for it they want the
benefits Pat but they don't want to have
to pay for it which is how it becomes
affordable and I really wonder what
percentage of Trump supporters benefited
from the Medicaid expansion or just from
any of the provisions of Obamacare I
mean it has to be in the millions right
absolutely and topher Spiro from the
Center for American Progress actually
tweeted out something about this which I
think makes a lot of sense when you look
at it saying quote we should replace
Obamacare with the Affordable Care Act
and be done of course joking but
pointing out that many people don't even
seem to realize that Obamacare is the
Affordable Care Act and it turns out
that while they condemn Obamacare
without knowing much about it it's
disproportionately Trump voters who
would be hurt if Obamacare were repealed
we have another Kaiser Family Foundation
analysis which finds that most Americans
who used that Obamacare marketplace last
year live in Republican congressional
districts policy analysts have concluded
that older and more rural Americans
would be most affected by a repeal of
Obamacare older and more rural Americans
were disproportionately likely to be
Trump voters low-income households in
the 32 states that expanded Medicaid
under Obamacare would be significantly
affected again another group that
disproportionately voted for Trump this
is why we can't even pay attention to
what these clowns want that because they
have no idea what the facts are yeah and
if Republicans repeal the Affordable
Care Act with nothing in its place I
mean 20 to 30 million people are going
to be kicked off their health care
coverage yeah and it's really just not
be good for them politically of course
and but but the concern is they'll still
find a way to blame Democrats even
though it's a Republican White House a
Republican House Republican Senate by
and large Republican governors they will
still find a way to blame a Democrat for
Trump taking away their Obamacare
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
I glasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five day home try-on from warby
parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
three hundred dollars for prescription
glasses with Warby Parker they started
just 95 bucks mine cost that including
lenses and for every pair sold they give
a pair to someone in need so to try the
five pairs and support the david pakman
show go to Warby Parker trial com /t DPS